les femmes conduisent aussi bien que les
oui ils font ils font autant attention
elle casse rien non il s'accroche de
temps en temps comme les autres mais
pareil est-ce que vous savez que le
début ce que vous venez de prendre était
conduit par une femme non et qu'est-ce
que ça vous fait de le savoir Orient et
si vous l'aviez su vous seriez quand
même monté dedans bien sûr je prends le
bus
par un homme
[Musique]
ou par un homme est-ce qu'on dit très
très bien généralement elles conduisent
mal si je peux je les évite déjà arrivé
d'avoir des accidents avec des femmes
non mais enfin très près je ne fais
jamais attention si c'est une femme ou
c'est un homme qui conduit ça me gêne du
monde donc vous estimez vous estimez que
l'un ou l'autre sont capables de
conduire mais encore comment peut-être
mieux que les hommes moi je ne fais
jamais attention mais si je vois qu'une
femme
ah si surtout si elle est jolie je monte
volontiers